foreign
artist but you don't have to be a
designer to get a designer look for your
designs
you can do this with the help of tools
in the digital era design is one of the
most important aspects of content
marketing the first impression is half
the deal if your content is not able to
catch the interest of your audience at
first glance then they might not be
clicking on it there are many tools and
services out there that allow you to
create great graphics and designer sets
but in this video we will explore canva
one of the most efficient and easy to
use tools out there when it comes to
designing hey everyone I am tusha
bariwal welcome to Simply learns YouTube
channel but before we begin if you enjoy
watching Tech related content consider
subscribing to our YouTube channel and
hitting that Bell icon to stay tuned
without further Ado let's move on to
today's session agenda we will start off
the session with an overview of canva
what is canva used for and why it's
gaining popularity next we will discuss
some of its best features moving forward
we will discuss the pricing of canva and
then we will end this session by
learning how to use canva what is camera
canva is a simple design tool that
allows anyone to create great looking
graphics and Designs it is available on
the web and as a mobile app with this
tool you can create social media post
invitations websites presentations and
many more it is a great for small
businesses that cannot afford a graphic
designer and don't have the time to
learn how to create their own Graphics
the best part is that anyone can create
a great looking design without needing
to download any software or even a
design skill anyone can create a
professional looking design by dragging
and dropping next let's discuss what is
canva used for canva is not just limited
to social media post it has other uses
as well with this tool you can create so
many things let's discuss some of that
app mockups mock-ups are detailed
representations of your app design this
includes all the final UI elements like
typography copy colors and visuals you
can also create amazing graphs mind maps
business proposals and prototypes in the
later part of of the video we will see
how we can get pre-made templates of the
following things in canva so now that we
understand what is canva and its usage
now let's understand what makes canvas
so popular the platform is free to use
to create professional designs you don't
need to spend much money on tools
however for additional features you have
to pay you don't need prior experience
or to be a graphic designer to use canva
best for small business owners online
entrepreneurs and marketers who want to
design things quickly now let's discuss
the best features of canva there are a
lot of features available when it comes
to creating different designs with canva
but we will discuss some of its best
features we will also cover a complete
guide on how to use canva in the later
part of this video but before we do let
us discuss some of its best features
produce different types of content canva
will give you the Liberty to create
different types of content like social
media post videos ppts and many more the
next best feature feature is pre-made
templates canva has a pre-made template
so you don't need to create designs from
sketch you can make changes to that
template and create amazing designs the
next best feature is drag and drop
feature canva doesn't require any coding
to design simply drag and drop to get
your work done
another best feature of canva is stock
images icons and fonts you will get a
lot of stock stuff like images videos
sound effects in the canva itself you
don't need to go any another website to
get stock stuff this makes it one stop
solution to create amazing visuals
theme feature you want to work as a team
for example you have five designers one
designer has created a design for your
next Facebook ads and you want another
designer to do an addition to that
Facebook ad design you can do this by
using a team features moreover if you
want Advanced features as a team you can
purchase canva subscription and again
that makes canva affordable because as a
team the cost of canva is divided among
the team let's discuss the last feature
in our list which is video transition in
2022 many companies are focusing on
video advertising canva gives you the
power to create amazing video ads for
your brand
how much does canva cost to understand
the pricing of canva we will go to the
website and see what are the different
plans available in canva to go to canva
website you just need to Simply type on
Google canva.com once you search this
canva.com on Google you will find the
first website as canva.com just simply
click on it and you will be redirected
to the official website of canva here
you can see there is a pricing section
plans and pricing let's check so
basically there are three Plans free Pro
and Enterprise what are these three
plans let's have a look by clicking on
this compare pricing button once you
click on this compare pricing button you
will be redirected to the page where
they have compared free plan Pro Plan
and Enterprise plan so basically this
free plan can be used by any individuals
companies or anything who wants to use
canva for free but but for the
additional features you have to go for
the canva Pro
and if you are a or if you want a
Enterprise some big company you have a
large team then you can go with the
Enterprise plan now let's take a look at
each of them so basically this canva
plan is for people from one to five
uh if you see uh this free plan gives
you 2 lakh 50 000 plus free templates
100 plus design types like social media
post presentation letters and more
hundreds of thousands of free photos and
Graphics invite members to your team so
in free plan also you can invite the
members and create your own team you can
collaborate and comment in real time so
collaboration is also possible in the
free plan you will get 5gb of cloud
storage so what are the changes in Pro
Plan like why we should go with the Pro
Plan if you see everything free has plus
so this simply means everything you see
here is included in the Pro Plan now
let's discuss what additional Pro Plan
offers so 100 Plus premium stock photos
videos or deals and Graphics so you will
get some stock stuff premium stock
stuffs which is not available in the
free plan okay if you see six lakh 10
000 Plus premium and free templates with
new designs daily so so every day there
will be new uh designs edit and uh you
can say update it easily save and apply
your brand or campaigns color logo font
and 100 plus brand kits uh there is a
very good feature which Pro offers that
is remove image backgrounds so suppose
if you want a PNG image you want to
remove the your background so you just
need to click uh on the remove
background button and and in just one
click your background will be removed
resize option also it will give so that
also a good option if you see in the
free plan we'll only get 5gb of cloud
storage
but in the Pro Plan you will get 100 GB
of cloud storage the last feature of
this canva Pro Plan is schedule social
media content to eight platforms so
there are a lot of social media
platforms available out there so you can
simply schedule your social media posts
if you see all the Enterprise plan uh
everything pro has plus so this this
simply means everything uh that we you
will see in the Pro Plan is there in
Enterprise and these are the additional
things which Enterprise offers like
control your team's access to apps
Graphics colors logos ETC control team
uploads into canva storage is unlimited
if you see in the canva Pro 100 GB
storage is there in Free plan 5gb
storage is there but in Enterprise level
if you purchase this one then you will
get unlimited stories that is also a
good feature if you have a good team
members like 25 plus of team in your
company want to use canva then it's the
best plan for you you can contact sales
so this if you click on that this you
will be redirected to the sales person
of the canva and they will offer you a
customized price so summarizing free
plan you will get at zero rupees uh if
you are someone who if you see on
monthly basis how how much it will
charge so for 499 per month is the
charges for the Pro Plan okay and uh 2
200 per month per person is the charges
for Enterprise level if you see on this
Pro Plan this 499 is uh if you purchase
this 499 plan five people can use this
one but if you see on the Enterprise
2200 per month will cost you for one
person so if you want a detailed
comparison you can scroll down and there
is a button compare plans you can simply
compare your plans this comparison is
based on design and Publishing
collaboration brand management Storage
security and support so that's how you
can compare the plans so as we discussed
a lot of things related to canva in this
session finally let's see how to use
canva we will go to the canva website
and see how we can create designs in
canva we will also check out the
different different categories that are
available in canva so now as you can see
we are into the canva website so let's
discuss how we can create different
different designs on canva simply go to
canva.com and the easiest way to uh
create any piece of content is simply go
to the search box and type anything
which you want to create for example I
want to create an Instagram post right
so I'll just search this and I can
select this option so if you see there
is a option of Instagram post simply
click on that
and you will be able to find different
different templates which you can use so
there are free templates available as
well as premium templates are also
available if you see that is a icon of
canva pro so all the templates which
have this particular sign
is comes under the premium
so you can explore and whichever
template you like you can simply go into
that and create that so before jumping
into creating and editing any piece of
content I firstly let's have a look uh
on the different different categories
that are available on canva so I'm going
to the home of canva and we will explore
what are the different different
categories we have at canva what are the
different types of things we can design
in canva simply go to the templates
option if we go on the templates option
you you can get lot of templates of
different different things we will see
that so there are categories available
business category social media video
marketing custom prints cards and
invitation education so if you click on
this business category you can see there
are lot of things we can design if you
see in in this video also we have
discussed the Mind map graph
so all these things you can create
suppose if you want to create a resume
or invoice or some business report some
business proposal mind map presentation
all of these things you can get from
here for example if I click on this
presentation option
I can get lot of presentation templates
which I can use and edit it for example
if I click on this one ah for example uh
I like this one this template right so I
click on this
I can customize this template
right and
if you see we have redirected to the
canva editor right here we can simply
drag and drop and we can edit anything
we can change the size of the font and
everything so let's design something
right so suppose if I want to add some
element right
uh if I want to add some shape so I can
simply click on this right and I can
create this one
okay if I walk I can also change the
color of this
I'm just showing you uh if I want that
this design so what I can do right
so like this we can add a shape if I can
change the shape color as well so
suppose if I want this to be in yellow
so we can get this company profile text
background and this particular shape
background yellow we can also increase
the font size from here okay so we have
I hope you understand the how we can use
the shape option you can check out the
different different things which are
available here on elements you will get
lot of things like tables you can add
tables Graphics photos videos audios
charts frames and collection so if I
want to add some graphic to this
particular
a design so how I can do this so I have
searched this skill
uh in the search bar so I'll get the
graphics which is related to skills so
uh let me just choose one image so that
we can add it here I have choose this
image
right so we can
add this image anywhere in this
particular design
we can resize as well right with this
option
we can animate as well if you want to
animate right so like this you can do
so there are multiple options are
available so you can explode this one
right that's how you can do different
different
uh Element Animations you can add if you
want to add please animation then you
can go to this option and you can see
page animations also you can do from
this
so that's how you will add graphics you
can same like the same process will be
there uh for adding the videos and for
adding the
audio files right and same thing for the
photos as well suppose if you want to
add some photos from your personal
computer then in that case you need to
go to this upload option and you can
also upload images from your own
computer or desktop or your laptop right
so you can upload anything from here
you can also upload any videos and
audios and there is also one option
available you can record yourself as
well so that is also very good option
available in canva so from your if you
want to upload something from your own
PC or system then you can select this
upload option otherwise if you want some
stock stuff then you can go to the
element option and search any keyword
which is related to the thing which you
want to add in your design and you will
get the results and you can add anything
from this element option suppose if you
want to add some text in the text case
you can go to this text option so there
are you can add a heading add a sub
heading add a little bit body of text so
all these three types of things you can
add on your design so and there there
are font combinations available so that
directly you can use so suppose if I
like this one right so I can apply this
one and I can customize this right
uh suppose I want to write this as a
game I'm just taking it as an example
right I can also customize this
with this option
and you can move this anywhere
wherever I want this I can add simply uh
drag and drop you can do that's how
canva works so there are different
different font combinations available
which you can use some are free so if
you see these four are free and then
here these font combination will come in
the Pro Plan and the Enterprise plan
there are some more option if you go to
this more section you can find different
different uh options available simply
explore that then you will get a better
idea but I hope you got a better idea on
how we can edit the edit things or edit
design in canva so these uh thing we
have added on the presentation right
let's go back to the home the same thing
you can do for the Instagram post and
anything like for LinkedIn post Carousel
post for resume the same process will be
there I'm going again to this template
option so that we will explode the other
categories as well so previously we have
taken the exam we have gone to this
business category and then we have
clicked on the presentation and we have
see how we edit on canva right the same
process will be there for everything
right you can edit anything for example
if you click on this mind map you will
find different different templates for
mind map
you can simply choose any of
these templates and you can customize
according to your needs let's see what
are other things available in business
if you see there are resume invoice
proposal reports are available the next
category of canvas social media on
social media you will find different
different templates for Instagram for
Facebook for tick tock LinkedIn
for Twitter right then again uh there is
a video category where you can create
video ads as well or if you want to post
somewhere on their social media then you
can create videos with with the help of
this uh video section you will get
different different templates then there
is a marketing category so you can
create your logo suppose if you want to
create a website low so you can do that
as well broker you can create newsletter
infographics you can create right or if
you want to use some infographics on
your website that also you can create
custom prints so t-shirt mugs sticker
photo book labels hoodie Banner
certificate so certificate also you can
create right if you go to this custom
prints then you can edit certificate as
well cards and invitation is the next
category in which you can find templates
of invitation card postcard and the last
category is education
on education you can get educational
presentation uh in the business category
you will get the business presentation
right but in the educational category
you will get educational presentation
educational video education infographic
online whiteboard so there are a lot of
things available right then uh there are
after the category there is a style
option on canva so you can choose these
as well there are themes available so
for example in companies we generally
brainstorm on something right so if you
explore this brainstorm so you will get
these types of themes right so you can
select the category right whichever you
want right you can select anything
whichever template you want then you can
select the style whichever style you you
like you can select that and then you
can select the theme so according to
that you will get the templates then you
can also there is a filter option of
free or Pro so suppose if you don't have
a Pro Plan right then I would suggest
you or I would recommend you to select
this free option so that you will get
the free templates so directly so all
these templates are free so you can
simply click any of them and you can add
it for example if I I like this template
right I can customize this template late
the same procedure will be there uh the
same thing that we did for the
presentation the same thing will be
there for this one as well the editor
will be same but uh there is one
different that is the content piece is
different so I can edit this according
to my needs or if I want to add
something to this one then I I show you
previously as well on elements we can
add anything right on the text suppose I
want to add some text here so that also
I can do I don't want these font
combination I want some simple right so
I can select this heading option from
here
once I click on this heading option I
can customize this for example I'll just
write my name
I just increase the size
and I'll just put it here
so I can change the font of this
particular uh name uh it's my name
Tushar so I can change the font so for
example I want open sense then I can
choose this font I can increase the size
of the font decrease the size of the
font I can change the color okay if I
want this to be in bold then I can do
this from by clicking on this I can
change the alignment from this option I
want something in pointers or less then
I can use this if I want some spacing
Suppose there are multiple lines you
have written some paragraph so on that
lines how much spacing you need so that
also you can do from this option effects
this is also a good option I like this
left effect if you see there is
something change in the design so if I
click on this none option you see there
is a different design right and if I
click on this left background will be
little bit Shadow or something like that
intensity I can control from here so
suppose I want to increase some the
intensity then I can do that as well so
that's how you will edit things on canva
so with this we have come to the end of
this session on canva I hope the session
was informative and exciting in case you
have questions about any of the topics
covered in this session or if you need
the resources used in this session then
please feel free to let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
practitioner will be more than happy to
resolve your queries at the earliest
until next time this is Tushar from the
simply learn team signing off thank you
stay safe and keep learning
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here